I know, to do what we do, you gotta be able to take abuse.
...and you gotta be able to have people talk crazy about you.
In this business, you gotta be able to have people disrespecting you...
...and you gotta smile and you gotta pretend like that's OK.
I want to apologize to the Academy.
I want to apologize to all my fellow nominees.
This is a beautiful moment and I'm not crying for winning an award.
It's not about winning an award for me.
It's about being able to shine light on all of the people.
Art imitates life.
I look like the crazy father, just like they said.
I look like the crazy father just like they said about Richard Williams.
But love will make you do crazy things.
Being able to love and care for my mother, my family, my wife.
I'm taking up too much time.
Thank you for this honor, thank you for this moment...
...and thank you on behalf of Richard and Oracene, the entire Williams family.
Thank you.
I'm hoping the Academy invites me back.